some people never go crazy
what truly horrible lives they must lead
nothing is worse than to finish a good
then reach over and find the toilet
paper container empty
even the most horrible human being on
earth deserves to wipe his ass
sometimes you climb out of bed in the
morning and you think
i'm not going to make it
but you laugh inside
remembering all the times you've felt
that way
people run from rain
but sit in bathtubs full of water
i guess the only time most people think
about injustice
is when it happens to them
if you get married they think you're
finished
and if you are without a woman they
think you are incomplete
what matters most is how well you walk
through the fire
people are strange
they are constantly angered by trivial
things
but on a major matter like totally
wasting their lives
they hardly seem to notice
if you have the ability to love
love yourself first
there is loneliness in this world so
great
that you can see it in the slow movement
of a clock's hand
the less i needed
the better i felt
the nine to five is one of the greatest
atrocities sprung upon mankind
you give your life away to a function
that doesn't interest you
do you hate people
i don't hate them
i just feel better when they're not
around
there are worse things than being alone
but it often takes decades to realize
this
and most often when you do
it's too late
and there's nothing worse than too late
if you're losing your soul and you know
it
then you've still got a soul left to
lose
almost everybody is born a genius
and buried an idiot
love is all right for those who can
handle the psychic overload
it's like trying to carry a full garbage
can on your back over a rushing river of
piss
genius might be the ability to say a
profound thing in a simple way
bad taste creates many more millionaires
than good taste
[Music]
you begin saving the world by saving one
man at a time
all else is grandiose romanticism or
politics
you have to die a few times before you
can really live
of course it's possible to love a human
being
if you don't know them too well
we don't even ask happiness
just a little less pain
there is always one woman to save you
from another
and as that woman saves you she makes
ready to destroy
life's as kind as you let it be
i often carry things to read so that i
will not have to look at the people
[Music]
great art is horseshit
by tacos
who wants sex
talks about everything
but not about sex
too often the people complain that they
have done nothing with their lives
and then they wait for somebody to tell
them
that this isn't so
some people like what you do
some people hate what you do
but most people simply don't give a damn
[Music]
there are only two things wrong with
money
too much
or too little
[Music]